it's been three months since two
powerful earthquakes struck Northwest
Syria they caused significant damage and
to countless lives
many families have lost everything
they are now attempting to rebuild their
lives despite the absence of a long-term
U.N response
five of my family's members died and I
lost my house my late children worked so
hard for more than seven years to build
this house and now everything is gone
the ngo's response did not match the
severity of the disaster as many
families are still Without Shelter and
are still waiting for help to come
ngos themselves saw significant damage
to their projects which resulted in the
loss of more than 250 humanitarian
workers according to the response
coordination group
nevertheless these organizations are now
expanding efforts to provide permanent
housing to the survivors of the
earthquakes using the resources that are
available to them
this is our fourth housing project for
those who have lost their houses this
project includes more than 400 housing
units we provided these houses for as
many survivors of the earthquakes as we
could and we're working on establishing
a fifth housing project to provide homes
to survivors who are still homeless
family is among the beneficiaries of the
housing project as he expresses his
gratitude he prays that all of those who
survived the earthquake get the same
kind of support
after evacuating my house due to the
damage we were fortunate to have a roof
over our heads again after spending time
without one my children could not
believe that we finally slipped under a
roof we hope that those who are still
homeless have a home again and can begin
rebuilding their lives
have already been struggling through
years of war and they are now in an even
more difficult situation
in addition to the 12-year conflict the
devastating twin earthquakes in
Northwest Syria have added to the
already significant challenges facing
the region ngos are sparing no efforts
to provide support to the victims of
both the war and the earthquakes which
left Millions without homes and
struggling to survive
Northern Syria